[Music]
hey what's up party people hopefully my
internet's coming through
loud and crystal clear while we talk
about the epic lizard punching monkey
movie of the year although the year's
not over yet we could be surprised
godzilla vs kong
i'm here with danielle i'm here with lon
uh we're gonna talk about the trailer
give all of our deep really uh
complicated
thoughts uh the real we're gonna really
dig into the thematic implications of
this film
what each monkey or lizard may represent
and then we're gonna uh show you some
deleted scenes we're gonna respond to
fewer questions we're going to tease you
with next week's eyes trailer you guys
know the drill by now
um so hit me what uh danielle
um what do what does kong represent to
you
um well for me kong represents the
futility of man um
uh but but also the spirit of man in
that um
kong was always willing to fight for
what he believed in and what he believed
in
was just i don't know big monkey stuff
that's not in my business
but he was always willing to fight and
when he has his charged up laser acts is
that to you
um the corrupting influence of
technology or uh maybe some type of
commentary maybe
some sort of luddite implications uh go
on proceed um
i like to think that him having his own
charging acts is a reference to
um humanity's own rise from the
primordial
goo um if you will it's definitely uh he
could have chose to fight without the
acts he does sometimes but the fact that
he uses it it's just a little bit of nod
to
our own evolution to be able to use
tools fascinating fascinating
and lon the geopolitical implications of
this film did you guys see that fox news
actually had a segment where they were
like
in why are business people always the
bad guys like why is the ceo
gotta be the bad guy in godzilla versus
cog and it's like
yes let's definitely look very deeply
into this film and what it has to say
about the world of finance and uh you
know corporate responsibility
yeah i think the whole thing i mean the
axe to me is
late capitalism oh of course
swinging the axe would be uh
globalization
or
of radioactive energy is woke culture
okay just a little between the lines
people i mean
hong kong oh it's happening in hong kong
pretty obvious symbolism there um so
yeah
ostensibly this is where we talk about
our deeper thoughts on the movie but i
have none this was an enormous cartoon
of a large monkey part punching a larger
lizard and the humans uh trying to
get them to do that or not uh i uh i
wrote a joke
on twitter where i referred to a big
surprise
long wrote a joke on twitter where i
referred to kong as a monkey and a guy
wrote back a little while later like uh
ape i keep waiting for people to do that
to me because i keep writing monkey too
oh it's gonna happen well cause that's
the truth like i know that
technically that kind of animal if it
were real which it
is not would be uh more like an ape than
a month it's like the android
cyborg robot pedants but it's also
uh like 200 feet tall so let's just like
call the whole thing off
where are the genitals man where are the
genitals jordan
roberts not happy with us
yeah uh look i don't know if you guys
have any deeper thoughts about this i
think this
to me was um the most fun i liked it a
lot more than the last one which dare i
say
had too many monster fights um when you
have him
continuously fighting from start to
finish it kind of lessens the impact
and while the human characters you could
do better
sure but they i think they give you that
bridge and that ramp up to
when godzilla and kong finally fight
several times it has more impact than if
it was just
ring the bell and they're punching from
the first frame to the last
i think what a lot of these discussions
kind of miss is that not all monster
fights are created
equal like godzilla king of the monsters
had a lot of scenes where monsters fight
but they were trying to do that thing
where it's like from the human
perspective it was a lot of like rain
and smoke and
debris in the way so you really it's
it's more like
a head and then a foot it's all and like
the the monsters
they almost look like they're fighting
in jello or underwater where it's like
all kind of slow
and deliberate whereas the monster
fights in kong skull island and then
this movie they're more like [ __ ] like
it's more like an
action scene it was current like a fight
and it's fun
and exciting just purely on that level
which i feel like king of the monsters
kind of misses
yeah this was wrestling like the only
difference is that like kong and
um kong and godzilla aren't cutting
their own promos
they're having the humoured camels for
them things like kong bows to no one
that's a thing if it was wrestling the
kong would have said
you know yeah i want uh i would watch
wrestling if at some point
uh they burrowed a tunnel into the
middle of the earth to call somebody out
and they left
that other person left out of the uh
center of the earth which is a thing
that could totally happen
i mean you're at this point introducing
enough human characters that you could
introduce to who are just like
very boisterous loud people with good
broadcast voices
and then they become your wrestling
announcers at the end like i don't know
why we don't have
ringside color commentary like we would
if this was wrestlemania like i don't
believe it he's grabbing the roof off
that skyscraper
where's that like that's what we're
missing they already have like psychic
links
sort of with uh with people on the
ground that could totally get them to
speak for them they
just where's jerry the kid is he alive
is he is he is jerry the king lawler
alive
yeah okay good yeah you know
mind meld with him make him make him
yell stuff uh while people jump off the
top ropes is he canceled i'm sure
something bad's happened with him i
haven't watched wrestling since 1998.
i mean any wrestler at this point
[Laughter]
anywho um let's just watch on his
trailer for godzilla vs kong because i
know we have so much more to say about
this movie
i just wanted someplace somebody to
refer to this as a slobber knocker is
that too much to ask
never the following trailer is rated s
for spoilers
i mean you can probably tell from the
title that godzilla fights king kong but
we tell you who wins
if that sort of thing matters to you
in a year where everyone realized we're
at the mercy of nature
the world will sublimate that anxiety
into watching a giant monkey
fight a giant lizard in a perfectly
timed release
before we snap and punch and or kiss the
mailman
i'm scared to see this in the theater
not because of the virus i've just
completely forgotten how to interact
with people
yeah pause i mean my personal space
boundaries have
grown to six feet or maybe beyond
i just having people like if somebody
coughs behind me in a movie theater
i might like crane kick them i don't
know
i wonder how it's gonna be when i get
back in a room full of people i feel
like there's a there's a pretty equal
chance that it'll be like
weird for a week or two and then we'll
all just like get back used to it or
that we're all like permanently damaged
like i have no barometer for what it's
gonna be like like
maybe we're all just like agoraphobic
for the next decade
or maybe after 10 days it's like signing
writing the wrong year on your checks
like
you get used to it again i'm honestly
not sure i get weirded out when i see
groups of people in movies that were
made 10 or 15 years ago i think it's
gonna be
i think it's gonna be a long haul i
think it's like a it's like a bad
breakup like it takes like the length of
the relationship
you know so it's gonna be it's gonna be
a year of being there's all that like oh
man this summer's gonna be like the most
epic party summer it's like
that may be i'm not saying no but i also
feel like there's a chance that
like after three days it's like right
we're all right back to like hey you
want to go to like a bar tonight hang
out like
i don't know i'm good i gotta work
i might revert right back to that after
like a weekend
we'll see all right keep going this
movie people are seeing this movie
good for them um keep going godzilla vs
kong
you've been moderately pleased by all
the legendary kaiju movies so far
now tune in for another bad sober good
with the buzz installment of the
sloppiest franchise running
where character and timeline continuity
is more of a suggestion
featuring characters they forgot to
mention were related
characters they forgot to mention
entirely and characters who forgot they
discovered the earth was hot
they did give sarah zawa the same last
name as uh kenwa nabe's character from
the other ones but to not even like give
him like a framed photo on his desk so
you're like oh that's his kid like you
expect us to remember the last name
of that guy from two movies ago right
but it's also that
they're introducing the idea that the
sun has really broken
from the father's whole philosophy like
everything
kenwa nabe sirizawa lived for was like
we should trust godzilla godzilla is
part of
our natural world and we have to like
maneuver around him and now here is his
son like
[ __ ] godzilla let's just make a robot
version like
what happened there i'm not saying you
can't do that but like you would think
if you're introducing that idea that the
sun has completely gone the other way
from his dad
there was some kind of background to it
like did they have a falling out and it
done a big conflict with them like
whatever on like the
third or fourth time through this thing
it's like
was bradley whitford supposed to be
skarsgard's brother
oh wow maybe i think
well they did that thing in king of the
monsters where corey hawkins from skull
island grows up to be
joe morton from king of the monsters and
they
don't let you know other than just
giving them the same name and expecting
you to just
remember that classic years later yeah
so maybe
who knows with this franchise they could
be sliding all kinds of stuff by us
yeah they explain the stuff we don't
need and then don't do these like very
simple little one lines
it could be a cutaway an image just a
pan across a
family photo or something like that i
will say um
the charles dance thing is really weird
because the post-credit sequencing king
of the monsters sets up that
he's the one that recovers the gideris
skull and then it just shows up at apex
so we have
like why would this radical
eco-terrorist environmentalist have sold
it to
like the billionaire capitalist
cybernetic guy
like that doesn't make sense i'm just
imagining charles dance gets like two
scripts on his desk and one is like
300 pages long for mank and the other
one is like six pages long
in colored pencil for godzilla
but um i was thinking like if they made
a deliberate choice to just not bring
middle ditch back like
this past few weeks they must have been
like what
what a what brilliant foresight we did
we did it everybody high fives
oh that's tj miller's music yes i saw
that one coming
miles out well done all right let's keep
going
i forgot they discovered the earth was
hollow in the last movie the vortex
was a tunnel into the hollow earth it
doesn't matter i knew i was right
but one thing remains constant
absolutely no one watching
gives a sh about any of it now make with
the monkey bites
that's the stuff meet the humans of the
monster verse
because i had to so now you do too
they're just here to yell at what's
going on
even though there's no way any of them
could possibly know that information
this is why godzilla attacked the apex
facility they're trying to replace him
it's the axe it's drawing radiation from
the core like it's charging
yeah it could be a scionic interface
it's just some lit up tubes man how
would you know that
but don't worry there's so much more of
that ridiculous
that's scenario there's a lot of that
where like something
like a monster will go and they'll be
like oh
it's it's his throat's a little itchy
it's like ah where are you getting this
from
but that scene he walks into a room and
there's literally just a skull with a
bunch of lit up tubes coming out of it
like it literally does look like a dj
booth which is the joke
that he makes a few minutes later and he
just like intuits
like like really complex impossible
things that are going on
and he's like dead right first guess
it's yeah i mean that whole
thing i don't think it's really
necessary to because they are just
it's two children and a podcaster
infiltrating like the most top secret
layers of the most evil corporation in
the world
and they're just all they do is spill a
cup of coffee at the end like that's
that's the big payoff it's very
expensive special
whiskey not car oh excuse me um but
they're
yeah dead white whiskey
yeah it's uh right it's chekhov's
bourbon that was established in act one
really they don't have anything to do
except move from location location and
call out
what's happening i feel like from a
screenwriting perspective
they're there so that we can explore
apex like
they didn't just want us to follow demi
and bashir
like and be there with the villain they
wanted somebody some way to bring
us into that facility and show us top to
bottom
here's where they're building
mechagodzilla i just i don't think it
was necessary i think we couldn't
we you've established demi and beshear
it would be like following
john hammond the jurassic park like why
not like you could just show us that
without needing the complicated bit of
business of the through
earth monorail system or whatever also
something that kind of got lost in the
mix
of uh between films was kyle chandler
being like
millie bobby brown i will never let you
out of my sight again like i will be
there
always and she is totally totally
shunted aside like
yeah this guy will raise you that's fine
i'm busy godzilla
godzilla's hurting people we don't know
why so rebecca hall
is like so we should go on this
really dangerous adventure like into the
center of the earth
i i should probably just bring this
little girl along
and there's no there's not even a
conversation about like [ __ ] i mean
should we bring this little girl into
the center of the air can we just like
zoomer if we need advice about kong like
it is
like seems like i don't know some kind
of group home maybe while we're
just just sitting rebecca hall will take
her back when we get back from the
deadly mission to the center of the
earth it doesn't come up
there she's fine anywho all right he's
from a tribe so it's okay
they all have a backstory whether it's
their dead wife
she was my rock my truth dead brother
what really went wrong on your brother's
mission
dead mom or screw it dead everyone
when the storm took over the island it
wiped out the native people
as they carry on the monster verse
tradition of hiring great actors
then making them say stuff like this
with a straight face right now
godzilla's out there and he's hurting
people and we don't know why
cringe as the overly dramatic dialogue
is way funnier than the intentional
comedy of the film
as you follow along with the most
obnoxious fictional character profession
the podcaster something bad is going on
here a vast
corporate conspiracy brian tyree henry
ranson raised his way through the
sharpest conspiracy theory jokes of
2007.
the illuminati running shadow economy is
ought to find a hidden colony for the
elite
water they put fluoride in it and millie
bobby brown returned
it was just lame right like i i just i
feel like
um conspiracy theorists used to be
funny and now they are
everywhere and poisoning our country and
it's just not that funny to me anymore
yeah i was just holding my breath like
hoping no one would ask him about
the jews yeah right they just feel like
any minute it's gonna be like and have
you guys heard about comet pizza and i'm
just like oh
okay okay yeah
he's such a good actor that like i i
wrote it in my notes but my first thing
was like did he sign on for this before
they nominated him for all of those
awards
um but it does i mean he looks like he's
having fun
so that's that's good but yeah the
conspiracy theory is not as funny
now in the brain i mean at least at
least though
like he's bringing some energy like i
appreciated that
like he's kind of like the bradley
whitford of this movie where it's like
at least they gave him a character and
he gets some attempts at
introducing some liveliness to it like
when there's monsters on screen this
movie is like big and exciting and
awesome and fun
and then the moment that the monsters
aren't there it's not that it's just
humans and we're innately boring it's
like these are boring humans like and
kong skull island they're they're
not boring humans like i don't know why
they keep giving us so many of these
scenes in like
a military installation where we're
looking at radar maps and it's a bunch
of very
serious sober face people like i'm sure
that is what it would be like if a
monster attacks but
who cares it wouldn't happen no matter
what so just make it fun
yeah and like i understand the impulse
to be like uh
give him some kids uh give him some
some wacky children to take care of but
but
at the same time like this isn't a kid's
franchise
really like this isn't the reason to be
there like why is
julian dennis in there like does he even
i kind of
the first time through i inserted myself
that he has a crush on millie bobby
brown so he's going along because he
just like
wants to get closer to her and then the
second time i watched it i realized
i just added that that's not even in
there
i'm doing their work for them like you
gotta at least
establish that he just shows up with a
van and he's like and it sticks with him
the whole time
he's like i got he said let's go like
what do you say
literally i have an accent no the key
and he makes the point several times in
the movie that he like doesn't want to
be there so we never
so go he's not an expert in anything
he's not related to anybody he has no
stake in this
no interest in millie bobby brown right
at least give me like oh he's always
wanted to talk to this girl but he's
never had an excuse and now
monsters here's this excuse like even
that would be
something yeah oh well next time
keep going brown returns as his kaiju
and on in training
theory is it makes docile easy to
manipulate plus this
boy is also there in this goofy subplot
that could be completely cut without
anyone noticing
you only need one group of humans to
follow in these movies okay everyone
else is there to either be squished and
or cheer when godzilla destroys their
home
with a title like godzilla vs kong they
better deliver on the fights
as they pit the titular titans against
each other no less than three times
i mean sure godzilla wins two out of
three because i mean come on
look at the guy and yeah
spend more time on his back i'm glad
they uh
i'm glad they gave a definitive answer
and they gave the correct one
you know we all want the monkey to win
because we're all monkeys
here you know it's team primate but but
look at godzilla he's he's he's a
dinosaur he can't fight a dinosaur
even with an axe i thought they did a
very good job though in this of
reinforcing like
people were like oh godzilla would just
be like totally dominant like i agree
that
godzilla's gonna win this fight but they
did stress that there are
areas where kong does have like a leg up
especially in terms of like
strategizing like godzilla's just gonna
like come at you with his sharpest or
most radioactive
parts every time whereas kong is like oh
i'm gonna like
pivot off of this building to come at
you strong like you know like he's
faking out and stuff like he's using his
primate logic
and i i like that that like it was it
was actually thinking about the fights
on the level of like
well what would be each of these
creatures strengths and weaknesses
yeah yeah i like that it ended with both
of them having respect for each other
uh oh yeah you got it because godzilla
does the knot did y'all caught me yeah
he did do the night he did like
a corona to pop into his hand like all
right your family now you know
they should have had one of those seats
where they like talk next to each other
but looking away from you yes
like you know where like like the rocks
looking that way diesel's looking that
way but like still
respect you know and then somehow
they're both in like modified toyota
supras and they just peel off in
different directions on the highway
it's been a long time
all right keep going and yes kong spends
more time on his back than riley reed
but the film will do everything in its
power to make you root for the big hairy
boy
he's friends with children he loves
snacks and he's got thor zacks
i mean come on the only endearing thing
godzilla does is destroy part of florida
sorry from pensacola in the comments
without them joining forces at the end
against a surprise third fighter what
the hell is that
what the hell is that what god's name is
a giant jaeger created to fight godzilla
danielle you were team mechagodzilla i
changed i changed
uh after after my boy went down still
love him props respect
uh i immediately it's like the shiny
it's the literal shiny new toy
as soon as i'm like a godzilla now
you're my favorite little metal boy what
are you gonna do
i liked him i don't know he his design i
guess i'm used to the old one which is
like equally lumbering and like
full of missiles and stuff like that uh
this one he was cool he ki he looked
pretty dangerous he had like a sharp
you know tail laser um oh i liked him
because he's dumb
yeah he's very dumb i mean i think
clearly one of the best moments of this
entire
film is when he comes to life on his own
and you get the like deep blue sea
moment of
the bad guy giving his villain monologue
like and you're watching mechagodzilla
in the background
yeah very cool fun moment like i that
that that's
that's what i want from this franchise
like give me big
dumb silly over-the-top fun beats now
they they
so his point for going into the center
of the earth was to find
the power source to then power
mechagodzilla
yes okay the the
the energy signature that they are able
to retrieve
from that lit up thing in kong's home
yeah he beams isaac gonzalez goes down
there and measures the energy signature
beams it up to the surface where they're
able to
uh you know recreate that energy
signature
a thing and uh and that's
the secret to powering mechagodzilla now
that means that they had completely
built
mechagodzilla they just had no way to
turn it on without also going to the
center of the earth
as you'll recall uh they're able to turn
it on and it could reach 40 percent
forty percent covered up okay enough to
kill one skull crusher
which by the way how did they know that
those are that's just the name
john c riley gave those characters for
fun
in skull island he was like i guess yeah
monarch put that in a file somewhere
that then
went on to become like everybody knows
this file and that's how
uh now this this teenage girl knows that
that's what those creatures are called
interesting that that came back around i
mean this all must have taken years if
not decades to put in place so maybe
charles dance just got
fired for financial mismanagement it was
like come on we gotta we gotta get this
thing going let's go the center of the
earth already can you be fired from your
eco-terrorism job is there like
the other heck of terrorists are like
look it's not working out
well all the seats are here the board
seats are like the
guy from vet the bad guy from venom you
know all the evil ceos that fox news
wants to take the side of
they're all they're all on the board
like you you're really behind
charles i love that uh one of their
other examples on that fox news segment
was robocop it's like they are those are
oh my god that is those are very
evil executives from 1987. uh the other
one was
was uh lord business will ferrell from
lego movies
very upset
i think that's that's just an evolution
because don't they write like every year
one of them writes like that actually
scrooge is good calms like we should
teach children mr potter from it's a
wonderful life and scrooge we're
actually the heroes of those stories
yes oh man conservatives are getting
funny and liberals are worried
i'm so scared so scared he's gonna have
our jobs
keep going billy loses human control and
fights godzilla
causing the two beasts to team up
against this man-made atrocity
and all three of them to team up against
the city of hong kong
everyone in hong kong yeah i like that
there's a there's a building
there like evacuate hong kong i guess
it's there to make us feel better about
this
no wonder this is huge every time you
cut to the building there's people
so see it on the right which for most of
us right now
is our phone even though it's probably
best suited for one of those theme park
rides with moving seeds
awesome uh do you guys remember
uh the universal studio lot tour when it
had king kong in it
and uh he had like banana breath i do
that was cool anyways it's my chris
farley show
segment yeah one of those lizards uh the
the dinosaurs that came out one of them
spit
right into my black girl hair so oh wait
was that jurassic park
the jurassic park yeah i believe that
was like spielberg saw that king kong
ride and was like oh we can do jurassic
park we can just use
this is gonna work so he thought he
could do all of jurassic park with
animatronics
because that effect was so cool oh wow
and then it was only later that
i thought let's use computers i thought
you were saying we could do
jurassic park the ride which is also
what you do no i mean
i mean yeah like wow we could have our
own theme park ride uh wait a minute
that's always broken and that was how
steven spielberg invented the log ride
[Laughter]
directed by steven spielberg the first
log flume was created
in 1995 by steven spielberg genius very
well paced
all right keep going flew the movie
that may not be the most intelligent
thing you could be watching
but you know what neither are we and we
spoke this movie into existence back in
from the company who has the rights to
godzilla king kong
and pacific rim so please please please
do a crossover where they all fight each
other and stuff
you're welcome pause story
we need a week off we should just do a
super cut of like times we've
predicted things or like spoken them
into existence
or everything we've gotten completely
wrong i don't know there's
there's enough for two montages
all right keep going yeah
i get knocked down but i get up and get
up again
reptile wins just make out already
you're perfect for each other
on today's show we're going to reveal
the horrible truth
but first i'd like to tell you about
squarespace
billionaires shouldn't exist becca like
a high mecha heidi ho
the chris hemsworth of the brothers
skarsgard let them fire
preteen titans and
physics sure yeah i like titans punch
out
okay not trying to kink shane but why
are all these monsters always trying to
spit in each other's mouths
that's not a thing real animals do they
learn this from watching people
that's gross yeah they keep doing that
move man they got a
real fixate because you could i mean if
you had like laser
radiation breath you don't need the
other guy to open his mouth you could
just
well if they're like really if they have
a tough hide you need to like go
yeah it's like the boys purposefully
like let me get this down your throat
like is that necessary
yeah it's either the front end or the
back end blonde either way you gotta
find a vulnerable spot on these types
it's like hey this is the ant-man
though thanos argue but again all over
again
yeah well that was fun that's a fun film
i think i had a
as much fun watching something at home
as i have all year uh of watching that
i think that that was a total throwback
blockbuster popcorn movie i wish i saw
it at a drive-in or something like that
um but uh we have this
i i i really enjoyed i i just i part of
me just is like at this point
we can do like rise of the planet of the
apes or whatever like that maybe cake
kong should have just been
the main character of this movie like
i'm almost getting to the point where
i'm like
the moshi capture's so good the
performances from the
from the kaiju were so good like we're
maybe evolving past meeting people in
these movies
i agree yeah just do sign language maybe
maybe have you know the
that little little girl and she could
talk to cobb like no
godzilla is our friend now and he's like
yeah are you sure little girl
all right i'd watch that yeah um sorry i
just had to find the script to pull up
uh some things i want to shout out
in addition to please subscribe to this
channel if you haven't already hit the
like hit the bell you'll never miss
another thing
uh and also joestar our own joestar he's
all grossed up
and he is sitting down with fenway jones
from jasper's game day to discuss
dungeons and dragons mental health
awareness and suicide prevention there
should be a link in the description to
check that awesome conversation out
and then uh we did miss a falcon winter
soldier episode 3 review but we will be
back this friday or at least eric and
roth will be back
at their normal time to catch you up on
all that
i can tell you what i thought i liked it
oh lon says it's good so you can skip
the review it's fine
uh we have some outtakes and deleted
scenes uh let's roll them now see what
got cut
plus this boy is also there because when
the other two characters think exactly
the same
give them a small boy to ridicule i
drink that one yeah i kind of figured
that
then making them say stuff like this
with a straight face right now
godzilla's out there and he's hurting
people and we don't know why
no offense to the other nominees but
give kyle chandler all the oscars for
saying that without laughing
starring optimus primal
and my axe return to monkey
king kong ain't got nothing on me apex
jones
apex predator i own an island on the
coast of pensacola
jagermeister afk
kid watanabe robot jocks
scars guardian of the galaxy
hits from the kong that looks good
bad monkey versus superior lizard
oh there you go simple as right i tried
for a little while to come up with a
uh x versus sever joke like can i arrive
like
ballistic apes versus and i tried it for
yeah too long before i was like nobody
even remembers ballistic x versus
ever oh we got some good questions you
guys from the live chat
um i want to start with this one uh from
chris sears
if you had to stop a kaiju from
rampaging through a city what strategy
would you use
using a mecca is great for movies but a
giant tiger trap may be more efficient
thoughts
well no because now i'm thinking about
the giant tiger trap because i had to
um uh i've seen like animals get trapped
and they immediately start pooping
um as like a fear mechanism so all i can
think of is like you have this thing
that can't be moved and you trap it and
it just starts
like going on whatever town you're in
and that could be obviously as
destructive
and disgusting i just i feel like we
they never
they always go right to like military
like immediately and it's like we know
that
missiles don't work so like there's no
point i would but we never use any of
the tactics we'd use to get for just
like an
animal like i don't like smear some
peanut butter on the coastline like try
to just get them
like you're not you don't need to kill
them just get them out of the city you
know
like i'm just imagining helicopters just
dumping peanut butter like
dumping sand tanker flights like that
put out fires just dumping peanut butter
at the back what if we just invest in
like a huge squirt
bottle and we just like if they get too
close to like a city just squeeze it at
their face like maybe they'll turn
around
it works for cats they're very hostile i
mean i'm living
in in the sticks or i'm living uh
underground
uh for me personally that's my personal
kaiju strategy
if in case of any kaiju anywhere you're
you're gonna just head inland yeah you
need like uh neon
genesis uh uh rules where all the
skyscrapers just kind of lower
down into the uh into the floor to make
room for monsters to fight each other as
you do
i think that's pretty standard in japan
actually already yeah i mean it's like a
hurricane a tornado
shelter which is like your standard
kaiju shelter just yeah like wait it out
um okay i'm skipping all the
uh uh genuine questions but i i am
generally more interested in these ones
uh by d.a barakas writes if you have the
tech to build mechagodzilla
is a bipedal lizard the best shape to
build a giant robot would human shape be
better what shape would you build it
uh i'm definitely going large human
right like if i've got
because you can do all the things where
you know we can make lasers come out of
the eyes or
or toxic um spit in your own mouth mouth
so i think but it's also are we biased
because we're humans so we just assume
that people are a better shape when
maybe it is something like a small tiger
well
i think the question is not maximum
efficiency because i think it's clear
that if you just wanted to build like a
huge
machine that would kill godzilla i don't
think it needs to be godzilla shape
it's that the point is to humiliate him
like we've got to prove that
it's true like why aren't we making
godzilla no that's damian
we need to become the alpha type right
we have to prove we're the alpha we have
to like beat him at his own game
and like throw it in his face so yeah
we're bullying him like with that that's
the point
it seems unfair because he doesn't know
we're he doesn't know he's playing the
game
so it's it's really unfair well look i
watched a lot of battlebots
and it turns out that the most efficient
shape is not the most visually
impressive it's usually a
wedge with like a little flipping rod so
i think if we can just
get something under his feet and then
like continuously to just keep tipping
him back
that is humiliating it's even what kong
uses which is he has the
downside of all of your classic uh
dinosaurs
the uh he's got a little dinosaur arms
problem godzilla so
you gotta anything that can use reach
you know like upsetting his balance and
then getting in from
outside that's how you that's how yeah i
think godzilla on his back would be it'd
be really
humiliating for him to watch him roll
over and just kind of use his tail to
kind of squinch himself back
up yeah he would slink off into the
ocean for sure after that
um that's i don't understand why these
fighter pilots are always like you don't
need to fly
right in here and shoot them in the face
like hey you got these missiles can go a
long way
just aim just like they're always like
coming in where a tail can just pick
them off
like just fly around the outside yeah
don't yeah come on
you don't have to engage that directly
right
um okay another another big one um lin's
is asking
what animal would you want to see turn
giant and join the fight
so this doesn't have to be a previous
monsterverse character just pick an
animal
supersize it and throw it in the mix
i'm always me so i'm gonna say corgi i
just am i'm gonna say that i want a
giant
corky just being cute with
stumpy little legs oh come on yeah you
know there's not
a uh probably because it's a you know
this was a
japanese sort of genre and like they're
they're using the animals that are there
every day local animals uh so we've
never gotten like a
bear kaiju that i can picture which is
very like american north american animal
but i think that would be cool
like yeah just get like a huge a huge
bear like a moose or something that's
more like our part of the world
i think it'd be funny terrifying to see
a giant goat
like because they can like really jump
high they could jump like four times
their height you know like a mouth yeah
they got those weird
eyes weird yeah those are weird-looking
box eyes or whatever
uh eat everything they eat everything
yeah just chewing on uh
uh chewing up buildings and spitting out
shrapnel and then like maybe doing like
a
like a little donkey kick action and
then just like when it goes
voiced by adam sandler
i'm a goat yeah yes i am still demanding
okay and then finally we'll leave you on
this um what are your thoughts on
godzilla 99
i remember watching as an eight-year-old
i've seen a couple times since then
and my last memory is that it kind of
holds up i'm sorry but i have to
disagree with you
wholeheartedly there wow
yeah between all the fish dumps and uh
matthew broderick and jon renau
and uh godzilla looking like a weird
little iguana
i don't think that movie holds up at all
not even dare i say the jimmy page p
diddy theme song
i think we're i think we're done i'm
done i'm out
i never need to go back there were some
good songs it did have a pretty good the
godzilla soundtrack was was not a total
loss but that that's the highlight of
the whole film for me
it also had do you remember that uh it's
got like the mayor
of of the town and then his assistant
are like supposed to be like siskel and
ebert
like they look exactly like shots at
like film critics throughout the year
and they're always like bickering and
like giving stuff a thumbs down it's
just like such a
weird per like are you really that
you're taking it that personally that
cisco and ebert didn't like your movies
roland emmerich combat i mean to me the
biggest knock on it is just godzilla
doesn't like
look like godzilla and so it never feels
like a godzilla movie at all it just
feels like
a big iguana attacking a city movie yeah
all right well uh those are all the the
most serious questions and i think we
gave this film the serious treatment
that it deserved i'm glad we did it uh
i'm glad we were able to do this
so fast i mean now that things are on
streaming like
boom boom boom like why wait uh it's
weird to do an honest trailer for a
movie that's like still in theaters but
the games change game has changed i'm
not saying we're definitely also going
to do this for mortal kombat but
yeah i'm thinking we do
can't wait not next week uh it's not out
yet so
uh next week is something that is one of
my favorites
of the year uh and i think we'll be
will give you a whole bevy of options to
laugh at uh i think you're gonna enjoy
it
i always do um and i always enjoy you
lon and danielle thank you for joining
me and thank you audience
uh we will see you tomorrow on sju
thanks for watching
[Music]
bye
you